bien alors là on était très négatif on
va essayer d'être positif on va faire
une interview bon côté alors comment
connaît déjà la leur mauvais côté on va
essayer de trouver le bon côté si vous
deviez dire quelque chose de bien sur
klaus barbie vous diriez quoi par
exemple
vous savez quand je défends barbie je ne
défends pas que quelqu'un forcément de
bien je défends quelqu'un et j'essaie de
comprendre comment il est arrivé à faire
ce qu'il a fait parce que un procès pour
être pédagogique pour être exemplaire
doit examiner tous les aspects d'une
réalité non pas pour excuser mais pour
comprendre si au contraire on ne regarde
pas tout à ce moment là on s'expose à ne
pas comprendre et le procès perd sa
valeur pédagogique
si on dit de lui c'est un monstre on a
éliminé tout débat se mons ne nous
ressemblent tandis que si on dit c'est
un être humain qui est arrivé à faire
cela on se pose des questions sur nous
mêmes et comment empêcher que ces choses
ne se reproduisent
et si vous deviez dire quelque chose de
bien sur 1000 cv que vous diriez quoi
bon coup droit je dirais qu'il se défend
pas mal bon coup droit je comprends
qu'un joueur de tennis entre si vous
deviez dire quelque chose de bien sur
saddam hussein diriez quoi je dirais que
la guerre qu on lui affecte le poste
dans une position la plus confortable
possible si vous deviez dire quelque
chose de bien sûr bernard bonnet diriez
quoi ça m'est difficile ils ont des
différentes versions que bernard bonnet
a donné de ce qu'il a fait d'où
l'expression de gérard bonnet blanc si
vous deviez dire quelque chose de
positif sur papon vous diriez quoi je
vous dirais que je ne peux pas par dire
quelque chose de positif pas pompeux des
raisons parfaitement personnel je
défends des vous le rappeliez les
militants du fln pendant la guerre et
papon été prêché de police à paris et
les l'auteur d
de nairas donald du 17 octobre 1 donc là
dessus ce n'est pas une sympathie
particulière pour lui et donc je ne peux
pas vous parler de lui de manière
absolument modéré
c'était
la table ronde
jacques vergès merci d'avoir été avec
nous mais je vous en prie à bientôt au
revoir
allez
à
il